featuring the work of a cyber watchdog
group at the University of Toronto
called citizen lab the group told us how
they had discovered Saudi Arabia was
apparently using some sophisticated
spyware made by a company in Israel to
track the phones of Saudi dissidents
including Friends of the murdered
journalists Jamal kasoori then the day
after our report a strange twist what
the New York Times called a case of a
bungling spy who apparently was trying
to trick the Citizen lab into revealing
sensitive information about how they
work here's an inside look with their
video about how it went down the city a
five-star hotel in New York City the
host a man using the name Michele
Lambert supposedly from a French
consulting company the target john scott
Railton of the citizen lab at the
university of toronto a watchdog group
which has been investigating how the
Saudi government and others have been
cracking down on dissidents okay in the
phone call to set up the luncheon
meeting conducted in French Scott R
Elton says he already knew something
wasn't right
the questions were strange he thought
someone was trying to spy on him I knew
pretty quickly that this was a ruse but
Railton decided to show up at the
Peninsula Hotel for the luncheon meeting
anyway and see if he could turn the
tables on the man he thought was trying
to spy on him since I've been working
with reporters from The Associated Press
since December on this case we decide
it's time to move towards a sting and
we're gonna see if we can catch them
red-handed trying to run this operation
and so that you sat down for lunch so we
sit down for lunch scott Railton says
his hosts steered the conversation
toward an Israeli company called NSO
which his group believes was helping the
Saudis to track dissidents so they were
trying to gather information from you
about the work that was left us that's
with a focus on the NSO group that's
right he is really conv that's right
Scott Railton says
he was recording Michelle and he says
he's sure Michelle was recording him
can I see your pen for a second all
right so usually when you talk to a
person you rarely aim the cap of your
pen at them for extended periods of time
I could tell that the pen that he was
using had a hole in the top and I felt
pretty certain during that conversation
that there was either a camera lurking
in there or a microphone but Scott
Railton had his own cameras and watched
as the reporter and the photographer
from The Associated Press moved in to
confront Michelle I don't have to speak
well actually I think you want to
because was a visiting company this
morning and you know it's very strange
she says it doesn't exist the AP
reporter Rafael Saturn tells the man his
colleagues in Paris could not find the
company he claims to work for number 77
[Music]
it strains your company it's not there
we can't really figure it out could you
is why are you did you get the we should
for sure there's a point he's very
unhappy as we follow him and the AP
reporter asks him some pointed questions
about who he works for and why his
company doesn't seem to exist
finally after making the rounds he finds
an open door towards the back of a
restaurant and scoots in it that's the
last we saw of Michel so who is Michele
well Michele according to reporting that
came out yesterday from first Israeli
reporters and then the New York Times is
actually named uh Holland I'm ugh a
Swede and he's somebody with a
background in as an officer but he was
spying on you you're convinced I'm
totally convinced that he was spying on
me we were put in a position where we
had to take some kind of special action
in this case and I think you know we did
what we had to do
I would hope though that this is read
also as evidence of something bigger for
years our work has been based around
showing that there is a commercial
spyware industry that's out of control
and that industry although it claims
that its products are being sold to
tackle criminality and terrorism which
is undoubtedly true I'm not arguing that
police with proper accountability
shouldn't have the ability and shouldn't
be properly technically empowered to
conduct their work but what concerns me
is an industry that will sell things to
states that have a history of lack of
accountability and bad behavior but
clearly you're doing something somebody
wants to stop I think that's right and
to me that's evidence that we're doing
good and important work and it renews
our motivation to continue our
investigations
a spokesperson for NSO the Israeli
company declined our request for a
company official to appear on our
program today
the spokesperson denied the company NSO
played any role whatsoever in trying to
spy on citizen lab and while all that
was going on with Susan lab Reuters
broke a major story about another case
of alleged spy of journalists in human
rights advocates
Reuters learned that former US
intelligence officials had actually gone
to work for the United Arab Emirates
what at first was supposed to be a
program to detect terrorists seems have
turned into an effort to target
journalists and dissidents using
techniques known to the former American
spy officials here are some of the voice
of the Reuters video posted with their
story an investigation by Reuters found
the group helped the UAE spy on targets
such as rival governments and militants
in an operation codenamed project Raven
it also targeted human rights activists
who were critical of the UAE s monarchy
the UAE s Ministry of Foreign Affairs
and the NSA both declined to comment but
hackers Reuters spoke to say project
Raven went even further putting some
Americans under surveillance joining me
now is one of the two waters reporter
who broke this major investigation Jones
shuckman Joel thank you very much for
being here this is quite a story how'd
you get onto it it's kind of it was kind
of crazy it was like one of those things
okay I think I heard about it from
somebody when I was at a bar and it was
kind of just like one of those tall
tales you hear somebody was telling me
that Daddy had heard people were like
leaving the United Arab Emirates and
leaving their jobs because they were
worried because they were being asked to
spy on other Americans and it just kind
of sounded like something that was too
crazy to be true and you know it's one
of those things that you would never be
able to report secondhand but very
quickly we were relatively quickly were
able to actually find the people that
this happened to and you know and they
shared their stories with us and they
had documents to substantiate their
claims and it was something it was one
of those things he kind of like couldn't
make up almost you know you had one of
the former American NSA officials
actually speak to you on the record
Laurie Strode how did you talk what did
she say
yeah so her story her story was
incredible and her story was that she
had been a you know an elite hacker for
the NSA in Hawaii
a you know targeting foreign governments
like China for you know for the US and
you know she got after a few career
setbacks she got this like you know what
she saw as being a great opportunity to
work for a intelligence contractor in
Abu Dhabi and she you know didn't
necessarily ask like that many questions
before she arrived there which is kind
of not that uncommon among intelligence
contractors who often aren't really
fully clued in to what they're gonna be
doing until until they're there on the
job and once she arrived she found out
that the mandate was was quite broad
that she was going to be working
directly for an Emirati spy agency
spying on you know terrorism suspects
but also human rights activists and
journalists and you know anybody who was
kind of like a political dissident who
spoke poorly of this of this monarchy
and you know she was she was pretty okay
with that for for a while for several
years and she did really well on the job
and she kind of put aside her kind of
qualms about it but then you know one
day she came upon you know some names on
the list and she's like well these
people actually are described as
Americans you know their their
nationalities American and they're
journalists here actually spying on
American reporters here and you know
that was like too much for her to
swallow I think that she went on the
record in this case because she felt
like this was a story that was already
so complicated and so shrouded in
mystery and she really thought that you
know it required that type of exposure
that type of credibility that you get
from actually having somebody who can
speak with that sort of authority on it
and actually having like that like a
faced a name to it and you know I think
thought it was a you know a very brave
thing for her to do absolutely Joe we've
got about 30 seconds tell me is the FBI
now investigating this was a law broken
yeah yeah so the FBI is investigating
whether the law was broken whether
indeed you know this this this project
is project Raven whether they were
involved in spying on Americans and
whether the American Intel were involved
in leaking you know classified
information or classified methodology to
foreign intelligence operatives
jellow Schuckman of Reuters thank you so
much great work